hallo liebe Freunde des gepflegten
Facebook Interviews am Dienstag dem 13.1
um 19 Uhr ist es soweit da stehe ich
rede und Antwort in der Panasonic Video
Zone und Link findet da unten in der
Videobeschreibung da geht es um das
Thema wie werde ich berühmt auf Youtube
also eigentlich was muss ich alles tun
um erfolgreich zu werden welche Tipps
und Tricks gibt es einige habe ich ja
schon oder eigentlich sehr sehr viele
schon hier im Youtube Buch erwähnt aber
vielleicht habt ihr auch Fragen auf die
ich noch gar nicht gekommen bin oder
Ideen also eine muntere Diskussion zu
der ihr jetzt schon eure Beiträge unter
dem Link posten könnt wir sind ziemlich
gespannt was da alles kommt haut rein
und dann bis Dienstag um 19:30 Uhr ich
freue mich 19 Uhr pardon 19 Uhr 19 Uhr
19 Uhr ich freue mich bis dann bleib
dran